and really seeing the results
and i like it
chrissy teigen isn't shy when it comes
to revealing cosmetic procedures she's
had done i did that dr diamond buckle
fat removal thing here
the 35 year old model recently took to
her instagram story to show off the
results of her latest plastic surgery
endeavor buccal fat removal which
according to the american society of
plastic surgeons removes the buccal fat
pad a naturally occurring pad of fat in
the cheek hollow area and is a seemingly
permanent solution to reducing the size
of your cheeks once the fat is removed
it does not come back and usually takes
between two to four months to see the
full results i'm obsessed with it
chrissy also reveals famous plastic
surgeon dr diamond did the job these
techniques are really honed to
to maximize somebody's
face to maximize their features
to create symmetry to create harmony the
proud mom has always been open with her
fans about her love of skin care and her
cosmetic journey in june 2020 chrissy
revealed on instagram she'd had her
breast implants taken out and shared her
scars a few of my friends keep having to
tell people
that i really got
my implants out because no one believes
it
these are the scars and in 2013 she told
et she's obsessed with good skin i'm
really big on skin i don't spend money
on anything quite like i do with you
know skin care products and face creams
and lotions but for me exfoliating is
really important i love looking like
glowy and natural and soft and and
pretty so i do take really good care of
my skin it's it's my number one thing
but when it comes to her slimmer cheeks
and newly defined jawline chrissy also
credits her sobriety
and since i quit drinking
i'm really seeing the results
and i like it the cravings cookbook
author first announced she quit drinking
in december of 2020 after receiving
holly whittaker's book quit like a woman
the radical choice to not drink in a
culture obsessed with alcohol from a
friend since then she's spoken openly
about the results in january chrissy
shared a pic on social media of her
husband john legend and their kids at
the lincoln memorial after attending the
inauguration of president joe biden she
captioned the pic in part just
incredible to be here sober i know
that's weird but it's like a different
world for me everything is new and
better it's actually life-changing
honestly but sometimes life happens and
in early september chrissy revealed that
she was celebrating 50 days sober she
marked the milestone by sharing this
sweet video with her kids miles and luna
and a very honest caption that read in
part today is my 50-day sobriety streak
it should be nearly a year but i had a
few wine hiccups in the road based on
her latest video we love seeing chrissy
smiling and living her happiest life i
like it
you